today I am convening the EU finance
ministers to agree on a bold response to
the coffee nineteen out break it is
arguably the most sizeable and ambitious
package ever prepared by the Eurogroup
it builds on unprecedented efforts
already taken by governments and
monetary authorities now we need a
European plan to help protect the most
affected and make sure the single market
will come out unarmed from this crisis
first a safety net for workers the
Commission proposed a 100 billion
program to finance employment protection
schemes second a safety net for
businesses the European Investment Bank
proposed the 200 billion guarantee to
support ailing firms especially SMEs
third a safety net for countries our
right to fund DSM has proposed
precautionary credit lines of up to 240
billion to ensure all countries have
adequate resources to respond this
emergency plan will shield our economic
and social tissue as we dive into a
recession but it cannot be separated
from the recovery which will shape the
Union for years to come this is not just
about surviving the virus it is about
getting our economies back on their feet
so today I will also call on ministers
to make a clear commitment for a
coordinated and sizeable recovery plan
we know we all know this is not time for
business as usual politics we must show
our citizens that Europe protects them
for them we must stand tall